and so I'm like but what are you doing
on my podcast right you're not scared to
be out here talking about it that's what
I was
are these lying well the first the first
thing is you got to find out I mean this
is in our society we've gotten to the
point where we're afraid to question
women right so that's called victim
blaming because somehow if you wanted
the details of the situation that she's
you know she's saying is a very vicious
crime
if you want the details she knows you're
going to blame her
so she's like I I don't it's on it's an
inappropriate to question a woman
so now at that point she's got you in a
situation where you just got to believe
it hashtag believe all women so now you
got to believe the believe it and let
everything carry out but like anything
any relationship is going to have some
things that are weird like first of all
we thought of grape as someone some man
jumping out the bushes in the ski mask
then it developed into some dating
encounter then it's now marital
situations that can be interpretated and
then they went away from the word now
with sexual assault that's essentially
what what but sexual assault opens it up
to anything that could be any damn thing
that's okay okay I was on this podcast
the other day and this girl said she was
coerced right right and I and I was like
okay so then I was like that's weird did
you sleep with him again
yeah
yeah why would you say
ing I'm trying to make too too much
sense
but but here's the thing there's people
that can claim that their husbands
assaulted them eight years ago in their
marriage but they continued to sleep
with him live with him and so forth and
then she can come out well you know he
did this at this particular point so the
problem is we have a lot of propaganda
out here that's telling men that we need
to take Women's Word at face value when
historically that's one of the worst
things you can ever do I would never
take any particularly women I would
never take their word at face value
because historically they've they've um
they've accused people of doing things
and people have lost their lives and
later to find out I
sorry I used to believe him
I would never yeah see I mean just like
they would seem so sad
and then but then it's like and then
then you think about it even further
right because because I just keep I keep
thinking I'm a thinker right and outside
of the norm so yeah so I was thinking
I'm like okay if he hit you right
right the average guy like I'm strong I
don't know if you I'm I'm built like an
athlete okay I I play Semi-Pro
volleyball
I deadlift 300 pounds okay yeah I kill
it you know unicorns are lifting so
nobody's gonna beat you up no no no
average guy could still beat me up oh I
said yeah
if someone if someone punched me that's
a dude like my face would be well that's
the problem with with women they might
be able to dish out a couple of hits
which aren't going to be very
significant but getting hit is always
different so I'm like if he abuses you
why is your face intact that doesn't
make sense to me and so then I'm like
then the other thing I was wondering is
I and then I'd say did you hit him of
course course
and she may have hit she may have hit
him first and still claims abuse but
here's a you know uh we we so we we have
we want to inform your audience check
this out did you know that
uh in domestic uh physical abuse 70 of
those cases are con are the woman
instigated
she could have either hit or used verbal
abuse or emotional abuse to get him to
respond so when there's physical abuse
where the man hits the victim which
would be the woman seventy percent of
the time the woman instigated meaning
she wasn't a passive participant meaning
he didn't walk in the door and kick her
it was instigated by something sometimes
it was instigated by physical abuse on
by the woman so but but these are things
that people can't talk about because in
our societies considered misogynist to
talk about these things and then the
other thing other things
you got so you got cheating abuse this
is the same umbrella of the abuse the
the grape I say great I say grape yes so
the girls will say tell me they'll be
like
I was graped and I and I'll be like oh
that's
we're gonna go there now but I ask
questions right and one girl straight up
tells me well I didn't know I was great
no no yeah that's so yeah just thinking
like okay okay
how do you not know right because if I
was if I was great
I feel like I would never yeah but you
would have to detect I feel like you
would have to determine if there you'd
have to have a true definition of what
that is but now we've gone up we've had
multiple definitions of what it is
so typically you can have a woman say I
was assaulted
but she only discovered that after her
reputation was dragged in the mud right
so she went to school and she slept with
this guy at a party she went back on
Monday to school and everybody knew
about it and then the girl said did you
sleep with that guy you a hoe then
another girl came did you sleep with him
oh well I really didn't want to oh you
were great see now now now she's great
because reputation is on the line so
these things happen once the reputation
gets dragged you have a person that is
getting raped also you do have women
that do I don't know if people know this
most of these what you would call grapes
aren't violent
most people who report one they're not
normally violent but see the idea of
what we have in our head is that
somebody jumped out the bushes and
shocked her and then she was there and
he had to beat her up that's typically
not what women are reporting they're
reporting someone close to them
took advantage or they stayed at the
person's house too long or they were
drinking together and they fell asleep
in the bed and then he or she passed out
and the person she trusted that's what
that's what people are reporting so what
we have in our mind
is not what people are reporting
but sometimes those things are
misconstrued too
yeah man I think most of the time let me
tell y'all something if you drink
alcohol
you're probably you know you're partying
and all that stuff and you're dealing
with late nights those are most of the
time that are going to get into some
sort of sexual assault
ourselves in those situations but they
look at me like I'm crazy like I'll say
how dare you hold me accountable
irresponsible yeah I I tell them that
I'm going
um because they'll always say like oh I
can't walk home alone at night in a dark
alley and I'm just like what where are
all these dark alleys that's my first
question and two I'm like I'm like
nobody can walk home alone nobody nobody
and at least if I get attacked as a girl
another dude's gonna help me right right
we do hear that women are unsafe out
there we're unsafe and people can attack
us I'm like I could get attacked too
what are you talking about like like I
can walk through an alley and everybody
be like uh you're good but um yeah these
are all things that we've been fed to be
truth and that's not necessarily true
we're vulnerable I think men are more
vulnerable uh in instances you know if
I'm dressed nice if I have jewelry right
I can lose my life and actually every
day you know women women want to be the
purveyors of being vulnerable but if if
I look at a man wrong if he has a bad
day
I could lose my life too I can get beat
up too so we have to always men always
have to be on guard and protect
ourselves no I agree like um
I mean it just if me and you are walking
in this dark alley right
and you and you and you get job
and you jumped and I get jumped like if
I start screaming another guy is gonna
like more likely to come then I think if
you started I'm not saying I'm not
saying either is a great situation yeah
but yeah it it it's um you know I would
hope that people do start you know at
least they'll call 9-1-1 right if they
hear you scream they might be alerting
because you know women screaming is
evolutionary being a sign of trouble
which do women do manipulate and they
overuse
tell you more so again about
manipulation right so
um you know women have learned that if
they do screen people respond it's like
a baby that cries learns the parent
responds so what they've done is
manipulated that sometimes they would do
this on the playground sometimes they
would do this you know somewhere and
they would scream or they'd go up to a
nightclub and when they're having they
do this thrilling pitch right to gain
attention
right
and it's not because it's an emergency
but she's learned that people will give
her attention by doing this squeal and
as a result
when women squeal now nobody does
anything
like if we if something happened right
now we're recording this and somebody's
screen right now we'd be like I wonder
if everything's all right
we wouldn't jump into action because we
know uh Sometimes women just scream
so they kind of shoot themselves in the
foot you know what I mean but it's a
manipulative as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible